Now that we've
prepared our data set,
let's use CART to build
a predictive model.
First, we need to load the
necessary packages in our R
Console by typing
library(rpart),
and then library(rpart.plot).
Now let's build our model.
We'll call it tweetCART, and
we'll use the rpart function
to predict Negative using
all of the other variables
as our independent variables
and the data set trainSparse.
We'll add one more argument
here, which is method = "class"
so that the rpart function
knows to build a classification
model.
We're just using the
default parameter settings
so we won't add anything
for minbucket or cp.
Now let's plot the tree
using the prp function.
Our tree says that if the
word "freak" is in the tweet,
then predict TRUE, or
negative sentiment.
If the word "freak"
is not in the tweet,
but the word "hate"
is, again predict TRUE.
If neither of these two
words are in the tweet,
but the word "wtf" is, also
predict TRUE, or negative
sentiment.
If none of these three
words are in the tweet,
then predict FALSE, or
non-negative sentiment.
This tree makes
sense intuitively
since these three
words are generally
seen as negative words.
Now, let's go back
to our R Console
and evaluate the numerical
performance of our model
by making predictions
on the test set.
We'll call our
predictions predictCART.
And we'll use the
predict function
to predict using our model
tweetCART on the new data set
testSparse.
We'll add one more argument,
which is type = "class"
to make sure we get
class predictions.
Now let's make our
confusion matrix
using the table function.
We'll give as the first
argument the actual outcomes,
testSparse$Negative, and
then as the second argument,
our predictions, predictCART.
To compute the
accuracy of our model,
we add up the numbers on
the diagonal, 294 plus 18--
these are the observations
we predicted correctly--
and divide by the total number
of observations in the table,
or the total number of
observations in our test set.
So the accuracy of our
CART model is about 0.88.
Let's compare this to
a simple baseline model
that always predicts
non-negative.
To compute the accuracy
of the baseline model,
let's make a table of just
the outcome variable Negative.
So we'll type table,
and then in parentheses,
testSparse$Negative.
This tells us that
in our test set
we have 300 observations
with non-negative sentiment
and 55 observations
with negative sentiment.
So the accuracy of
a baseline model
that always predicts
non-negative
would be 300 divided
by 355, or 0.845.
So our CART model does better
than the simple baseline model.
How about a random forest model?
How well would that do?
Let's first load the
random forest package
with library(randomForest),
and then we'll
set the seed to
123 so that we can
replicate our model
if we want to.
Keep in mind that even if
you set the seed to 123,
you might get a different
random forest model than me
depending on your
operating system.
Now, let's create our model.
We'll call it tweetRF and
use the randomForest function
to predict Negative again using
all of our other variables
as independent variables and
the data set trainSparse.
We'll again use the
default parameter settings.
The random forest model
takes significantly longer
to build than the CART model.
We've seen this before when
building CART and random forest
models, but in this
case, the difference
is particularly drastic.
This is because we have so
many independent variables,
about 300 different words.
So far in this course,
we haven't seen data sets
with this many
independent variables.
So keep in mind that for
text analytics problems,
building a random forest model
will take significantly longer
than building a CART model.
So now that our
model's finished,
let's make predictions
on our test set.
We'll call them predictRF,
and again, we'll
use the predict function
to make predictions
using the model
tweetRF this time,
and again, the new
data set testSparse.
Now let's make our confusion
matrix using the table
function, first giving
the actual outcomes,
testSparse$Negative, and
then giving our predictions,
predictRF.
To compute the accuracy of
the random forest model,
we again sum up the cases
we got right, 293 plus 21,
and divide by the total number
of observations in the table.
So our random forest model
has an accuracy of 0.885.
This is a little better
than our CART model,
but due to the interpretability
of our CART model,
I'd probably prefer it over
the random forest model.
If you were to use
cross-validation to pick the cp
parameter for the CART
model, the accuracy
would increase to about the
same as the random forest model.
So by using a bag-of-words
approach and these models,
we can reasonably
predict sentiment even
with a relatively small
data set of tweets.